so I think aside from writing all these
scripts that you do and rewrites but you
also do like speaking engagements and
you go to I do I speak a lot of
conferences actually and I do a lot of
workshops which are a lot of fun I love
teaching and so and then I also do
consulting when people hire me to read
their scribes so I do that too which is
also great because it's also another
form of teaching when I do consulting
usually they obviously give me a feature
that I'm giving notes on but it's really
not about notes for that particular
scribe it's about teaching them how to
become better writers and so that's a
lot of fun for me too
and so they can go to your website which
will have underneath a video and yeah
the information is there yeah okay great
let's say I'm a hypothetical person
attending one of these conferences and
then I'm one of the people waiting in
line to talk to you and you know just
say hey really enjoy the information I
was wondering dot dot dot and that is
how can I become a working writer so I
don't have to work a part-time job I
just want to go right into it I think
that everybody's journey is so different
in this business you know if you want to
become a doctor you go to med school you
do your residency and you become a
doctor and you know you go work at a
hospital that's not the way it works in
the film industry the key to success in
the film industry is being opened
opportunities and being able to see them
when they come everybody has sort of
this type A personality plan right where
we go okay so I want this by this date
and then I'm gonna try to do this and we
think of that as being ambitious right
that we have a plan we're working toward
something and there's absolutely nothing
wrong with that but if you get too
obsessed with that so much so that you
don't see opportunities that come to you
that may not fall in that plan you can
miss out on a lot of opportunities and
so like I tell this story I've told it
before when I was in film school a
friend of mine does Amba movies and
there's only five girls in my class and
so I was always a zombie and one of his
movies because he had no one else to
choose from Anna years later
we were graduated and he's a real
producer and he calls me up he's like
hey Christine I'm doing a real zombie
movie do you want to come down and be a
zombie just for old times sake and I was
like sure I'll come down for one day and
so I go down and I'm sitting there and
I'm in full zombie makeup like my hair
is he's out I'm green and I'm sitting
there with the background and if you've
ever been on a film set you know that
you know background it's pretty boring
you're sitting around most the time and
but it's fun and it's a great day off
and as I was sitting there I meet this
guy also a zombie who had just arrived
from from Boston and he had gotten a
part on an HBO series called Carnivale
this is actually several years ago and
we started talking and he tells me that
he has the rights to the soft Broadway
play and he's looking for someone to
adapt it so at the end of the day he was
a cool guy really nice I tell him well
you know if you need someone to adapt
that into a screenplay for you let me
know and then the very next day the
director calls me it was like I heard
you're adapting our off-broadway play
and just was like oh yeah I did commit
to that yesterday but sure so well let's
meet and talk about it
so I go to meet with him and the
director and this guy and I realized
when I get to the coffee shop we're
gonna meet I don't know what they look
like because we were all dressed as
zombies and so I have no clue what they
even look like so we finally find each
other and we end up doing a short and
that short premiere at the LA Latino
Film Festival and that was great it was
a great experience I got to walk the red
carpet wonderful I just did it to be
nice right after just doing something to
be nice for my friend from college a
year later I get a call from them and
they're like you know what Christine we
have some good news based on the short
that we did
we've got financing to make the feature
do you want to write the screenplay for
$25,000 and I mean yeah of course no I'm
gonna say no to 25 grand so especially
when I was still in debt and all and
this was during that that period of five
years where you know I was just doing
things to be on film sets and to network
and so yeah I did that and again that
was an opportunity
very still very proud of a film that
film became Hotel California starring
Tatyana Ali had a great cast it
premiered the following year so 2 years
later as a feature at the LA Latino Film
Festival and did very well so again you
have to be open to opportunities I never
went in to playing a zombie thinking I'm
gonna meet somebody who's going to have
me write a short that we're gonna then
turn into a future it doesn't work out
that way just make yourself available
and try to meet the right people and
create situations where people owe you
favors and they want to work with you
again and when you can do that then
those opportunities will start to come
but you've got to be able to recognize
them when they happen that's a great
story I feel like we're in this sort of
like hacking bubble where everybody's
got it wants to try to like make this
quicker and make that quicker and if I
follow this person on social media they
might they might just put me in the
project which it all happens I know that
it does but I feel like we were in this
new era of everything's got to be
quicker and it sounds like you although
I'm sure you wanted certain things to go
faster you did things a little bit of a
different way but I think a lot of it
was I never went into all of that
thinking that there was gonna be some
payoff
I just loved being on film sets I loved
meeting other filmmakers I loved taking
an off-broadway play and adapting I'd
never done that before and so for me it
was more about the love of doing those
things rather than the payoff of somehow
I can I can turn this into a moneymaker
for me or somehow I can make this turn
this into a rung in my career it was
never ever like that so you know the
Deepak Chopra says you know we make
every decision based on love or fear
right so all of those decisions when I
look back now I know we're based on the
love of writing and the love of becoming
a screenwriter not the fear of am I
wasting my time helping this person when
I should be helping that person because
they're gonna
pay me quicker they're gonna get me into
their movie or they're gonna do this it
was never like that for me right I like
this your intention was different it
wasn't about what were you gonna get
right and when you're not looking at
what the pay when you're not trying to
see what the payoff is down the line
there's no there's a disappointment in
it when the payoff doesn't come because
you're open to whatever that's gonna
lead you to next right and so your since
you're quoting Deepak Chopra I'm gonna
quote Louise hey since we're going there
and her thing that I love that she would
say was well that's not a million
dollars and people stop on it and walk
away from it because again we're so
we're looking for you know I mean I'm
sure everybody would love to walk the
red carpet but it took these little
steps it took you going to the set it
took you talking to this guy it you know
it forming a relationship a business
relationship and then then that happened
but people just see that result of oh
she's on the right carpet a that I want
to be there exactly and they don't
really know what it takes to get there
and and that's why again you have to be
so careful about letting yourself become
resentful like looking at other people
and where they are and saying why can't
I get there why can I get there
that energy is not well spent so focus
on why are you writing if your goal and
just honestly be honest with yourself if
your goal is to make money if your goal
is to be famous if your goal is to be
recognizable and have a name then this
may not be the career for you because
there there are easier ways to get those
things than by being a screenwriter so I
think if you just can say I love writing
I want to see what today brings and
enjoy every moment that you get to be on
set you get to be talking to directors
whatever you're doing you know these
writing conferences are a great example
when you go to these writing conferences
people are there because they just love
to write they're just soaking it in and
it's such a creative inspiring
environment spend your time doing those
things right and take every piece of
information that you can and and learn
and become better at what you do because
the gratification that you
from becoming really good and writing
something and saying wow this is pretty
amazing that I mean nothing compares to
that not walking a red carpet not seeing
your name on television nothing compares
to that feeling
you